oui oh tu ressembles et toi tu ne sort
vas mai hélas je tenais voilà qui dit
serais jamais malheureux parce que tu as
que la mer tu la tiens dans telle
qu'elle ne te fait pas peur
aux monty tu dis même pas de quoi pour
que tu veux parce que
yeux trop grand pour savoir où commence
les yeux d'un homme que tous les océans
que la nuit petit vie commun
la forme qu'elle désire je veux tu
tu as des yeux
n'ont pas su retenir
lui qu'il ait peur tu peux me dire ce
des yeux
qui dit que la musique tu là au bout des
après pelé enfin ouais mieux non que tu
à fait venu je et tu es oui elle
qui ne sait pas faire demain tu as le
doigts tu la connais par coeur tu te dis
tu as laissé tomber pour avoir eu le
coeur d'un ange et le sourire d'un loup
temps d'avoir des souvenirs tu as les
nous
tu joues avec la vie tu joues avec
l'amour et pour que toujours
titre riche avec le temps tu triches a
toujours et au fond ce temps fou tu as